we got a great show tonight first andy
i'm told you had something you wanted to
share with us yes conan i did um i'm not
sure how many people are aware of this
but today is a pretty special day
it only comes once a year every august
24th i've been waiting all year to say
it happy national waffle day
[Applause]
there's something everybody should say
[Applause]
[Applause]
great hold it hold it hold it what
okay i think it's great andy that you
planned all this and and you're having a
lot of fun and everyone seems to be
enjoying it but today is august 25th
okay
are you sure about that yes
yes it's yes and you said national
waffle day is august 24th it is that
means it was yesterday
not today
oh
well give them back come on
till next year
[Applause]
[Laughter]
people started throwing them people
started throwing them back at you yeah i
need them back
[Laughter]
[Applause]
look at that
fantastic
what kind of what kind of animals
[Applause]
i'm glad everyone had a good time i
still feel like an ass
[Laughter]
all right andy i'm sorry i know that was
a big disappointment anyway we got a
great show tonight terrific program
we're gonna have
[Applause]
uh
i'm sorry i forgot about that all right
that's fine uh from glee and nbc's
hollywood game night we love her you
love her emmy award-winning actress jane
lynch is on the show
[Applause]
come on
[Music]
come on
[Applause]
why do i come out every night and tell
topical jokes
i should throw waffles around
that's the answer
[Applause]
oh
god knows where these have